Good morning, Hank. It's Saturday, August 3rd, 2013, which means that it's
Esther Day, the day that, in memory of our great friend Esther,
we say "I love you" not to the people we're romantically involved with, which is easy enough,
but to the people it's sometimes harder to say "I love you" to, friends and family. So…
(Sigh)
I love you, Hank.
(Chair clicks) I love you, too.
-G'awww!
Thanks, buddy.
-So for those of you
who don't know, Esther Earl was a Nerdfighter
that we met at the first LeakyCon—
-Who we met, who we met, who we met.
-That we met.
-Yeah, who.
-So for those of you who don't know, Esther Earl was a Nerdfighter
who we met in—I almost said it again.
So for those of you who don't know, Esther Earl was a Nerdfighter that
(Hank) That's just how we talk, now…
-No, it's not! I know! I refuse to accept
(Hank laughs)
-the proliferation of "that" when one means "who"! Esther Earl was a Nerdfighter
we met at LeakyCon in
2009 in Boston, where you really played your first, like, major concert.
-Uh-huh. Yeah, I sold my first CDs ever.
(John laughs)
-And look at ya now!
-Hah!
Still selling CDs outta the back of your trunk. Esther was a dear friend to us and a really important Nerdfighter.
She died in 2010 when she was just sixteen,
but we remember her on this day and every day by trying to spread her message of love.
-What a great thing to say, when asked what you want people to do
-I know.
-in your memory.
-I know. I said to Esther, uh, we're going to do this holiday for you, it's going to be called Esther Day,
it's going to be on your birthday as long as we make Vlogbrothers videos;
what do you want it to be about? And that's what she wanted it to be about. She wanted it to be about
love between family and friends. So, a Valentine's Day for the rest of love.
And I think that's pretty awesome.
So, uh, Esther, we miss you;
Nerdfighters, happy Esther Day, thank you for being awesome; Hank, I love you, soak it up, you won't hear it again for 365 days.
-Love you, too.
-Best wishes!
So for those of you don't—so for those of you who don't know Esther Earl was a N—
-Actually let's just, I'll cut you off
I'll just be like
-K.
-I, I'll, I'll just
-Right.
-I'll be like, right right right, yeah.
-Right, right.
-Okay. Esther… Esther Esther, Esther, Esther was a—Esther was a—
Esther Earl was a—Esther Earl was a Nerdfighter we met
-(Hank wheezes)